in a way you've gotten guys um a best
picture nomination i i'm thinking about
ridley scott who used your improvisation
and gladiator was it true that there was
only like 25 pages of a script for
glasses
that sounds absurd to me how do they go
into a production with 26 people they
didn't know that what do you mean they
don't know that well the studio think
they have a script right right
um and other producers think they have a
script but when ridley and i sat down
together and we went through it page by
page and we mark stuff that made no
sense or that was silly that you
whittled it down to 26 pages yeah it
might have actually been 22 now i think
about it yeah and then the next movie we
made a few years later we started with
like 45 pages and i said to him one of
these days mate can we make a
like a real movie with the script yeah
yeah we haven't done that yet but i
would think that would be scary i hear
you're a guy who you know when you're on
a roll and you're winning academy awards
and you get nominations and one movie
after the other is just a [ __ ] you
know blockbuster i would not want to
start a movie
that only had 22 good pages it was scary
as hell right and i i was on my way to
the airport a couple of times because it
was like what are we going to do because
all this expectation and responsibility
and i didn't know what we were doing you
know right and the thing is is what i'm
good at
is learning about [ __ ]
right and learning my dialogue
there's nothing to do
yeah if you don't have a script you
don't know what you're doing but you
know
in the conversations where it was just
ridley and i sitting in his office and
the things that he was already showing
me the things that were inspirations to
him i really just have one line going
through my head you know it's 184 id
you're a roman general and you're being
directed by ridley scott just keep
turning up to work you know um but yeah
you know
once we kicked off
me and ridley on a set together like day
one it was absolute you know he did this
little test on me day one you know
he walks up to me yeah we're on the set
of gladiator i've walked onto the set
i'm dressed as a roman general
in full metal armor on those first few
days right so it's not comfy right right
i walk under this battlefield he's got
terraces of
siege machines and
soldiers and horses and and this like
sway the forest has been sort of cut to
look like it's burning and
there's like 400 barbarians in the tree
line and i'm standing oh my god i've
never experienced anything like this he
just comes up to me goes i'm just gonna
shoot you
contemplating i want you to look over
you to your right
and i want you to see a small bird
in the tree
perhaps it makes you smile
the bird takes off the bubble fly away
and i want you to watch its flight and
its flight
brings you back to the battlefield
and what's actually in front of you and
he goes and action so i do that and
i'm pretty sure i did every single thing
he asked and i put little strokes of
color on certain things and then i
brought
the attention back to the battlefield
and he just came up to me
you and me are going to be [ __ ] great
together mate
i think it was it was a test it's a
direction test just to see if he would
if you would if i would listen if i
would do what he asked and if i could
accomplish that are you a legacy guy do
you think about like your children
watching your movies
um
i definitely think about how my kids
will view things over time it started
with the little one saying all his
friends at school had seen gladiator and
he wanted to see gladiator and like bob
you know you're like three or four or
something like that they haven't seen it
they're just
fibbing to you and he was like i really
want to see it so
i set it up one night for him and a
couple of other people i pushed play and
and uh 20 minutes later they wanted to
stop so i could go up to that house
where my mum and dad are right we're
about about to have dinner and my mom's
like my mum's like um so teddy did you
did you like movies oh grandma it's one
of the worst movies i've ever made
dad was just yelling at everybody he was
yelling and then he lost a dog and then
she sung all the little blue horses and
it was very upsetting
that's the great thing that levels here
right that's uh that makes you one of
one of the one of us